[Music]
our picture of the earliest moment the
universe has been evolving and I'm happy
to say in some sense as more empirical
support that it did before the discovery
of the Higgs field implies that you can
get fields that freeze in empty space
and that's a central part of what we
think happened in the very early
universe and if we could detect
gravitational waves from the Big Bang
we'd have a window on the universe back
to a time when it was a billionth of a
billionth of a billionth of a billionth
of a second old telling us answered
questions about the origin of the
universe as we as we know it
ideas that I speculated upon in my last
book for example and Newton and for
which we have new evidence and I've
described in my new book but because the
temperature of the universe and the
energies of particles was so extreme at
that early time when the entire visible
universe was contained in a region that
was smaller than the size of an atom
there's a wonderful symbiosis between
large scales and small scales and if we
can probe the early universe back to a
time that I described will actually be
probing physics on scales that is much
that are much smaller than we can see at
the Large Hadron Collider twelve orders
of magnitude smaller and scale or higher
in energy than we can probe with our
highest energy accelerator now to build
an accelerator that would directly probe
those energies we would have to have an
accelerator that's not just twenty six
kilometers around as the Large Hadron
Collider is but whose circumference is
the earth-moon distance and that's not
going to be built in our lifetime
probably ever so we may have to rely on
the universe to give us new information
and where that's why we're looking for
such signals when the universe was a
billionth of a billionth of a billionth
of a billionth of a second old our
current picture suggests a field very
similar to the Higgs field froze in
space but it was in what's called a
metastable state so like when you if you
have a beer party and you put beer in
the freezer because you forgot to until
the few minutes before the party and
then during the party
you forget that it's in the freezer and
you take it out later and you and it's
their liquid and you open it up and
suddenly it turns to ice and the bottle
cracks
the beer is in a metastable state at
that temperature would rather be frozen
except it's under high pressure the mini
roots of pressure it freezes
instantaneously releasing a lot of
energy as our universe cooled we think
the same thing happened basically a
field that frozen but in the wrong
configuration and as the universe cooled
suddenly boom like those beer bottles it
changed its state releasing a huge
amount of energy creating the hot Big
Bang now the interesting thing is while
it was in that metastable state storing
energy
general relativity tells us that if you
have a filled and empty space it's
storing energy it produces a
gravitational effect that's repulsive
not attractive so during those that
brief time gravity is repulsive and our
expansion of a universe started speeding
up faster and faster and faster and the
size of our universe we think increased
by a factor of 10 to the 30th in scale
or at least 10 to the ninetieth and
volume in a time interval of a billionth
of a billionth of a billionth of a
second okay that means it went from the
size of an atom to the size of a
basketball in a short time and that
rapid expansion produced characteristics
which pervade the universe today the
fact that our observed universe looks
flat the fluctuations in the cosmic
microwave background radiation came from
quantum fluctuations that happened
during inflation inflation is the only
first principles idea that it's that in
principle explains why our universe
looks the way it does and what's
wonderful about it is it doesn't require
any exotic ideas of quantum gravity or
theories we don't have it's based on
ideas that are central to our current
understanding of the standard model of
particle physics just extrapolating them
somewhat so it's very well motivated
even though it is hard to believe that
it can have happened but we think it did
[Music]